[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALLAN LIVINGSTON:
Today Rishi and I
are going to run you through how
to surface data driven insights
from the G Suite admin platform.
And also tying in with BigQuery.
So we're going to
see if we can--
I thought we were sorted.
If we can get the slides up.
Let me first give
you some background
on why this is important.
Right?
So you saw today at the
keynote a lot of the speakers
talking about
moving to the cloud,
and how there's so much more
data now that's in the cloud.
And it's great that
there's data in the cloud.
But it's only really useful if
you can get insights from it
and if it is actionable.
And that's what we're
going to talk about today.
Specifically, we're going
to zoom in on security.
We're going to talk about
some other elements,
but I think security
is a key piece.
Because if you really
think about it,
that's very much what is
on CIOs' minds these days.
And so one of the things that
having detailed reporting does,
is it allows you to move from
a standardized security posture
to ones tailored for
your organization.
So if you think about a
standard set of policies
that you might have, that
might be either too permissive
or too restrictive
for your organization.
Or it might both at the same
time for different groups
of your organization.
By having detailed
reporting and insights,
you can determine where you
need to tighten the controls
and where you're OK.
And so we're going to
run you through that.
And the way that we do
that is through reporting,
and it allows you to
do a number of things.
It allows you to assess
where your risk points are,
and we're going to show that
in a few different elements.
And also, very much
importantly, it
allows you to make
timely intervention.
So when you detect
there's a problem,
you need to be able
to act on that.
You need to be able to
do something specific.
You can set security controls.
You can also set up
DLP, which allows
you to control your sharing
policy based on content
and based on teams and
things like-- we're
going to go back that.
And audit allows you to
understand ongoing incidents
and respond to them
really, really quickly.
And finally, we look
outside security.
The other piece
from reporting is
to really understand
how organizations
are adopting the G Suite.
Right?
When you saw in
there-- the keynote,
everyone's talking about
how the G Suite transforms
your organization.
Well, it only really
transform your organization
if you use it.
And what we found at
a lot of customers
is that you'll have certain
pockets where they're really
using a lot of collaboration
and some other pockets
where they're not.
And a lot of times
that indicates
that there may be some
trainings or some warnings
need to flow from one
area to the other,
so that your whole
organization is really
taking advantage of all
the benefits of going
[INAUDIBLE] with the G Suite.
And so there are
three main elements
to our reporting platform.
It's got comprehensive data.
What I mean by that is, you
want to go deep and wide
across the G Suite
products there.
We've got all the logos, or many
of the logos of the G Suite,
and we continue to add more.
And you go wide by
covering all the reports
and then having a lot
of detail reports.
We've got 55 usage reports
on the Admin console, 9 audit
streams, and 18 alerts.
And all of this is
really, really increasing.
And so that provides
your baseline,
your key pieces there.
And then we want to have
an extensible platform.
APIs that allows us to push the
data out to where you need it.
OK?
So partners can
integrate with the APIs
to customized solutions, and
we can also send the data over
to BigQuery and run some really,
really interesting analysis.
And we're going to
show that today.
And then finally, all of
that-- you're doing all of that
not just so that there's data.
You're doing it so that
you can get insights,
and that you can act
on those insights.
And we're going to show you
how the reporting system ties
into that.
You can develop insights,
you can surface them,
and then you can, most crucially
as I've said, act on them.
So there are three
particular types
of reports that a reporting
platform provides.
We've got domain
and usage reports.
We've got over 100 metrics in
the reporting API in this area.
We've also got audit.
And that's about getting near
real time updates on user
activity and across all
the core G Suite apps
that I talked about.
The final piece is alerts.
Admins can choose from
two predefined alerts
to create custom alerts, and
they also create custom alerts
from the audit stream.
And then developers
can push alerts
in through the reporting API.
Rishi is going to give us
an overview of how reporting
is set up in the admin console.
RISHI DHAND: Thanks, Allan.
Good evening, everyone.
So I'm going to talk briefly
about all our reporting
capabilities that we have
today on the admin console.
The first important thing
that I want to talk about
is on the domain level.
So admins have this
requirement to see
at a domain level, what are the
top things that are going on.
So our domain level reports
are split into categories.
The first section being
the highlights section.
We realized that admins
are very busy people
and they need a quick
snapshot of what's
happening inside the company.
So the highlights page
provides a 360 degree view
of all the important
things that are
happening inside the domain.
Right?
From, what's the seven
day active usage, what's
the file sharing status
inside the company,
are there any users
who have suspended,
who are blocked,
are there any users who
are nearing the quota--
and that's a clue for admin
to go and purchase more quota.
So these are really
important inputs
that an admin can get
a quick glance off.
But that's only good for
getting a quick snapshot.
What if an admin wants
to get a more deep dive
information into each of
these different applications?
So for that we have
aggregate reports.
Aggregate reports provide,
at a domain level,
data on each of the services.
So for example, if you
want to know how many files
exist inside your company?
How many files are shared
outside the domain?
How many encrypted emails
exist in your company?
In a world where mobile
device management is becoming
very important,
admins would like
to know how many
manage devices exist
inside the company, broken down
by iOS, Android, and so on.
So aggregate reports provides
that level of information
where admins can go deep dive
into each of the services,
each of the device
management attributes,
and even export this
information into a Google
spreadsheet or a CSV and
do further drill downs.
The next category that I
want to talk about is--
we have spoken about
domain level reports.
But what if admin wants to
drill down at a user level?
For example, if you
as an admin want
to roll out two-step
verification
inside a company, which is a
very powerful way to secure
it account.
At that stage you want to
know which users are enrolled
in two-step verification,
which users are not enrolled,
and for those who
are not enrolled,
you need to inform them.
And that's where the user level
reports become very important.
They provide you granular
data at each user level.
And we provide three different
views around user level data.
So you could have
a security view,
where you can slice and dice
by all the security related
metrics.
For example, you want to know
how many external applications
have my users installed.
Given that there's
a lot of sensitivity
around external
third party data.
So that's a very
important attribute.
The second one could be how
many users have enrolled
in two-step verification.
The third one could be, are
they installing less secure
applications or not?
Are they using security keys?
Are they sharing files
outside the domain?
So that's the security view.
You could also have pure
collaboration and adoption
view of user level reports
just to discover how many users
are actively creating docs?
How many users are
sharing these files?
Because the company
has gone Google, not
just for cost savings, but
also to bring about a change
in the collaborative culture.
And that report
helps you discover
what are the collaboration
trends happening
inside the company?
Are there specific users
who are not using docs
as much as other users?
And that's a clue for an
admin to basically go in,
conduct maybe some
trainings for these users.
So that's what makes user level
sports very, very important.
And I want to highlight
that these reports offer
a lot of flexibility.
You can download these reports
in a Google spreadsheet
or a CSV.
We can do advanced
filtering, you
can do sorting on
top of this data.
So there's a lot of
flexibility that is offered.
The next one that I want to
really highlight is audit.
All the reports
are great, but what
if I want to know
what's happening
right now inside my company?
What if I want to
get a real time
update into what files are
being shared outside my company?
What if I want to know what
third party apps are getting
installed inside my company?
That's where audit comes in.
Audit is the backbone of all
security and investigation
work.
And we have nine
audit streams that are
available on Admin Console,
which cover all the major core
G Suite applications, Gmail
Drive, Calendar, Groups.
And you get a real time feed
into every single activity.
Now imagine the scale
of this feature.
Every single event that the user
is doing inside the company,
right?
From viewing a file to sharing
a file to downloading a file,
is all captured.
To give you some stats, we
process almost a billion events
a day, just on Drive audit.
That's the scale that
we are operating at.
And these events are
used by our admins
to troubleshoot when a
security incident has happened.
These events are
used by partners
to build really advanced
tools on top of it.
So it's really a backbone
of all the security
related investigation
work that happens.
I also want to highlight--
we also have a device audit.
So you can now see
every time a device gets
routed, every time there's
an OS update on the device.
So you can get a real
time feed on that as well.
The next vertical
here is alerting.
We realized that admins
are very busy people.
They cannot come to reports and
keep checking what's happening.
That's where alerts come in.
We've offered a set
and forget experience
where admins can simply
come, choose from one
of the 18 predefined alerts--
for example, suspicious log in.
Just go and turn
on suspicious log
in on your manage
alerts section.
And you will know whenever we
detect any suspicious activity.
And we apply a wide range
of intelligence signals
to detect whether there is
a suspected hijacker who
has come into your domain.
So we use that information.
You could set alert on, say,
a change of Drive settings.
That's very
important, especially
if you have delegated
super-admin responsibilities
to other delegated
admins, and you
want to keep a tab on what
the other delegated admins are
doing.
So predefined alerts
are a great way
to be aware of what's
happening inside your company
and make timely intervention,
avoid any security breaches
to happen.
And if you have a very
custom requirement where
you want to track a specific
event or a specific file,
that is also possible.
So you can go to Drive audit,
or any of the other audit
streams, do the filtering
on the left side,
and then set an
alert on top of it.
That's where your
custom alerts come in.
I also want to talk a little
bit about the reports API.
Now, all of the stuff
that we just spoke about
is great on the Admin Console.
You can come run your
reports, you can do audit,
you can do alerts.
But what if I have a
very specific use case
and that my company
needs to achieve?
What if my CIO has
come to me and said,
create a collaboration
dashboard for our company.
What if my CIO has
come and told me that,
OK, create a security
dashboard for my company.
This is where it's
very important for us
to give all of this data to you,
which you can use and derive
programmatically, and
build whatever you
want to build for your company.
Or have this API
given to partners.
And we have a lot of talented
partners on our Google Apps
Marketplace who have done
great things with the reporting
and audit API.
And build advance use cases
to meet our large customers.
So reporting API is
a powerful mechanism
to get over 100 metrics.
And through push
notification you
can create workflows built
on this particular API.
We have about two0 plus
partner integrations,
and I'll briefly talk about
one such integration, which
is Better Cloud.
So they have done a good
job of using the reporting
API to build a two-step
verification reporting
interface.
They also have an apps
explorer interface
where you can discover third
party apps or track quota
users.
So this is just one example.
There are a lot of other
partners on Google Apps
Marketplace who have
integrated this API,
and it's helping them
meet sophisticated use
cases, like DLP, custom
workflows, and so on.
But this I'll hand
it back to Allan.
ALLAN LIVINGSTON:
Thank you, Rishi.
So, yeah.
So there is an overview
of admin reporting.
But let's try to put
this into context
with some specific examples.
And so as admins, we
hear two general classes
of requests from CIOs, CEOs,
chief security officers.
It's basically,
you've got how do
I secure my users, my
domain, my company?
So you've got security
in risk management.
And then, how do I
ensure that my users are
as productive as possible?
That I'm actually
transforming my culture
by moving to the cloud?
And that's when we come into
uses in adoption reporting.
And to do this we can
use our audit logs.
Now the audit logs provide
near real time access
to events that are occurring.
So we can use those to
detect what's going on,
and then we can set
appropriate policies and rules
to protect the
data in the domain.
Now admins can slice
and dice audit data
in a number of different
ways, and we're
going to go over that now.
And so things like--
we've got here how to track
external file sharing.
So this is something
that we've seen
that's come up an awful
lot as companies have moved
to the cloud more and
increasingly put more and more
sensitive data into Drive.
One of the first things that--
first questions
that we got was, how
do I know that my data is safe?
How do I know what's going on?
Maybe someone could just
be sharing it everywhere.
Before, they had
that sense of control
when they had it on premise.
And when they move
it to the cloud,
you lose that sense
of control, and you
want to understand what's
going on with your data.
And that's where this comes in.
So Rishi is going to
show us a quick demo
on how you can detect this
and what kind of actions
you should take.
Thank you, Rishi.
RISHI DHAND: Thanks, Allan.
So as Allan just mentioned,
file security around Drive files
is really, really critical.
And we have built some
really advanced tools
that I would like to
showcase today and see
how admins can protect their
data using these tools.
So let's say, I'm a
user and my manager
shared this sales
forecast document with me
and said, hey, do some
additional enhancements
to this file.
And I want to work
on this from home,
and my company has a
secured access from home.
So what I'll do is,
I share this file,
and I say, anyone with a link--
so that I can go back
home and do this--
can edit.
And save.
So I haven't put my [INAUDIBLE]
I'm being very smart here.
So my name doesn't show
up in the sharing list.
And then, let's see
what the admin sees.
Now I'm the admin.
I'm going to the
reporting section.
And I will check Drive audit.
So there you go.
I just have got an
alert over here saying,
confidential sales
plan has been shared.
And when I go to my email
I've also got an email saying,
this user has changed the link
sharing visibility from private
to anyone with a link.
Now, this is a red alert
for me as an admin.
I have a user who
has shared something
confidential to
anyone with a link.
And this can lead to large
scale security breaches,
because a link is
almost like a password,
so anyone who has a link
can go into the file.
So I go back to my admin
console, I click on the file,
and first and foremost, I can
go back and change this option
so that this file is secure.
Now I've done this, but
this is a reactive step.
I can't do this for
every single file.
So what is the
solution as an admin
that I can get my mental peace,
and set policies and control
so that my users don't do
these accidental mistakes.
Right?
Like they don't put the
security of the domain address.
So I would like to show you
that we can now create rules.
So I go to the admin console.
And this a our
brand new Drive DLP
feature that we have
recently announced.
And as an admin, I have a list
of pre-defined templates--
Drive data loss
prevention templates--
that I can choose from.
Or I can create from
a blank template.
So I select one of them.
I can rename.
And I can do a host
of other things here.
While I'm creating this
rule, I can either assign it
to an organization unit.
Or, even better, I
can use Google Groups.
I can assign it to a bunch of
users inside Google Groups.
We have heard this request
from a lot of customers,
that they would like to
see more and more policies
in the settings being
assigned to Google Groups.
So this is one such example
where we have done that.
And on the content side,
with a predefined template
I get three templates.
But I can customize this
and add more out of one--
and pick one out of 50
such predefined templates.
Say I choose credit card number.
And the third field here
is very interesting.
Drive DLP does
flagging of files.
And if I want to be
very, very precise
and avoid any false
positives, I will
choose a very high confidence
threshold, which not only looks
at in case of
credit card-- number
not only looks at the
credit card number,
but it also looks at some
keywords around the number,
say expiry or name.
And it does that
kind of a matching.
So I do that and
I'm done with this.
And then within the actions
I can not only notify,
which I was able to do
with my custom alerts,
but I can actually block
external access, which
is a very powerful way
to secure your data based
on content scanning.
So I've done this.
I've created and
activated this rule.
And let's see what
happens on the user side.
So now I have another
doc and I'm Rio,
and I've been asked to work on
some of the sensitive team data
and I try to do the same thing.
And I'm trying to share it
with, say a consumer ID.
And there you go.
I get an error saying, this item
contains credit card number,
and you cannot share.
Right?
So this is a great
example of how
admins can protect sensitive
data stored inside Drive files,
and also audit it when
such situations happen.
So I just want to highlight
another thing here.
As an admin you can go back to
your DLP interface and check
rules audit.
So you will get a
list of all the files
that are matching your DLP
rules and run detail drill downs
on top of this.
With this I will go back to our
presentation to our next topic.
ALLAN LIVINGSTON:
Thank you, Rishi.
So shows you a
really powerful way
to detect and then control
the sharing of Drive files.
And it's really powerful but
quick, and that's the key.
That was the design
principle that we
had when we thought about DLP.
We wanted to make it not
cumbersome, really automatic.
Give users a good experience and
give admins a good experience.
And that's the idea with all
of our security features.
And so every time, as
the cloud continues
to get more and more powerful
and you add new capabilities,
you also have to
secure it in new ways.
And third party data
access is a great example.
So third party apps
are really powerful.
You can integrate with
G Suite using our API.
And you can extend the
capabilities of the G Suite
and integrate G Suite data
with your wider workflows.
So that's a great capability.
But on the other
hand, we've also
got to ensure that we're
adequately monitoring
and controlling that.
And that's where access to third
parties and logging in controls
around that come into play.
And so Rishi is going to
run us through a demo of how
you would do that.
How you would first
detect the behavior
you're seeing in third
party applications.
Is it what you expect
your user to be doing?
Are they doing this
responsibly or not?
And then how you
can control that.
So for Rishi, if you can
go to the demo, please.
RISHI DHAND: Thanks, Allan.
So I'll quickly show
how, as an admin,
I can track all the third
party apps that are currently
being used inside my company.
So I'm back to the
admin console and I
go to my reporting section.
And I go to the user security
report, which I spoke about.
And this report has a column
called external application.
So I choose that, and I
say, greater than zero,
just to scan all the users who
have installed applications.
So there you go.
It has very quickly
told me, these
are the users
inside your company
who are using
external applications.
So I click on one of them.
Our favorite, Rio.
And we go back to his security
section inside reals page
and there you go.
So I see he has installed
a particular thought
by the application I
see this app and I say,
OK that's not in my approved
list, so I said, revoke.
And I say, revoke.
Now again, this is
an example where
I have taken a reactive step.
My user has gone
and installed it,
and I have gone and revoked it.
This is not scalable.
We want to give admins control
where they can set policies,
so that users know
which apps to install
and which apps are
not authorized.
Now let's see how
he can do that.
So I'm going to show you a brand
new feature that is currently
in testing, entrusted
tester to limited customers.
And there you go.
So you have G Suite
API permissions.
This is a new section that we
have created which shows you
what scopes are
currently allowed,
what data permissions
are currently
allowed inside your domain.
Now notice that you
can also go and check
on what applications
are currently
being used inside your company.
So there you go.
I'm able to filter by
application scope, what
apps are being currently
use inside my company.
And I can go back to the
security permissions page
and block any one of them.
So I say, disable contacts,
and it disables contacts.
So from here on,
users will not be
able to use apps that
have access to contacts.
Now if there is a use case
where I want to explicitly allow
a particular application
inside my company,
that's pretty easy too.
I go to my installed
applications,
I open this button,
and I say, trust.
The moment I trust this
application, what it does
is it starts
honoring, or allowing,
any access done by this
particular application.
So now admin has created a very
safe playground for his users,
where they are free to go
and use applications that
are authorized, request for
applications that are not there
in the trusted list
from the admin,
and admin can do
his due diligence
and agree to give permission.
So that way this
is a good balance
between not stopping
the innovation that's
coming through the code by the
apps, but at the same time,
making sure these
third party apps
are using data in
a secure manner.
With that I'll hand
it back to Allan.
I'll just go back
to the presentation.
ALLAN LIVINGSTON: Great.
Thanks, Rishi.
And so that's a really powerful
app, and as Rishi said,
a powerful set of capabilities.
That ability to balance,
allowing innovation,
giving the users what they want,
but also controlling the way
data flows.
Now let's talk about
another example
here, which is tracking
suspicious logins
and acting on those.
And so if you think about
one of your primary risks
you're going to see as
an admin or as a company,
it's compromised accounts.
And you know a
lot of simple ways
that accounts are compromised.
Things like, just very
wide password reuse,
poor quality passwords.
The other thing that's present
and has been, and continues
to be a big problem,
is phishing, basically
fake pages that trick users
into putting in their passwords.
And it's still an
extremely common problem
and it doesn't look
like user education is
going to solve that.
And so it's something
that we have
to be really aware
of that there's
a lot of, either targeted
spear phishing attempts where
you going to go
after individuals,
or just broad based phishing
is relatively common practice
and relatively successful.
And so obviously
as an admin, you
want to be able to detect
that kind of behavior,
and you want to act on it.
And we're really excited by
the capabilities in this area.
And so Rishi's going to run
us through a real quick demo
in that regard, and
show us all the things
that we're doing there
to prevent hijacking,
which is obviously a huge, huge
problem you're going to see.
RISHI DHAND: Thanks, Allan.
So I'll quickly show you
what tools admins have today
to track suspicious logins, and
then take proactive action just
like how we have seen in
the case of file sharing
and third party apps.
So I go back to my
reporting section
where we have an audit
stream called login audit.
Now here you will
see that admins
are able to track in real time
what users are logging in,
from which IP they
are logging in,
and I can also filter
based on a specific IP.
So I can copy, paste an IP,
and put it in my IP list,
and there you go.
So I'm basically able
to understand which IP
this particular user is doing.
So now I'm a little
concerned about, OK,
this IP is unfamiliar, what can
I do to prevent such things.
So I can go back to this
particular user account
and see if he has used two-step
verification, because that's
a very powerful way to
prevent any phishing attempts.
So I see he's not using.
And then I can basically
go back to my report
which shows how many users are
using two-step verification.
So I go back to my
security report,
and I check two-step
verification enrollment.
And I say, show me all
the users who are not
using two-step verification.
There you go.
So now it's showing me the
trending of all the users
who are not using,
and in my domain
I only have 8 users
who are enrolled.
So this is a big problem.
I only have a few
users that I enrolled
in two-step
verification, and I want
to enforce it as a policy
to protect my domain.
So I go back to the
security section,
which has the list of policies.
I go to the basic
settings, and I say, OK, I
want to go and enforce.
So there you go.
So now I have this
screen where I
can decide to enforce
two-step verification by OU.
So for example, if I want
to enforce it on my vendors,
I can turn this on,
and I can turn it
on from a future
date, because I want
to give some time to
my users to enroll
in two-step verification.
And this is the new section that
we have recently added, allow
two-step verification methods.
Where admins can choose
not only to enforce
two-step verification, but
they can take and bump up
the security further by
enforcing only security keys,
which is the new way to
actually authenticate
for a second factor.
Which is a very powerful way
because it uses the hardware.
So I can say, only
security keys and save it.
So that's how an
admin can protect
against phishing
attempts by enforcing
two-step verification.
And with this I will go
back to the presentation.
Back to you, Allan.
ALLAN LIVINGSTON:
Thank you, Rishi.
And that showed an
example of security keys,
which is a really unusual
feature in the security world.
Because if we're
honest, most times
enhanced security is kind of
a trade off with usability,
right?
Putting extra elements
of security in place,
kind of, degrades
user experience
or makes it more of
a hassle for users.
And security key's a
really unusual area,
because it doesn't do that.
It's extremely easy to
use, and it's much easier
to use than other two-factor
authentication mechanisms.
And it's also more
secure, because it's
unphishable You can still
do sophisticated phishing
accounts on other second
factor log in mechanisms.
But you can't do that
on security key because
of the hardware connection to
the computer, which is amazing.
And it's also, just as I
said, it's really easy to use.
We use them all
the time at Google.
I think everyone at
Google uses them.
And there's a study up on
the Yubico website, who's
a manufacturer of these things.
And it showed that Googlers
actually spent four times less
than using standard
second factor mechanisms
by using these security keys.
These little-- let me just pull
this out of Rishi's computer--
this little guy right here.
And you basically just
stick it in your USB port,
and any time you want two-factor
auth, you just press it.
And it's super, super useful.
So let's talk about admins.
And if you want, who is
watching the watchers?
How does this work?
And this is
particularly a challenge
for larger organizations
that, a lot of times,
are going to have
delegated admins.
You're gonna have a
number delegated admins.
And it's possible that
delegated admins--
while delegation is a
really powerful tool,
it allows you to
spread the load.
It's also possible that
delegated admins, perhaps,
don't have the same
level of training
or the same understanding of
the impact of their actions.
And for that we've got to
keep a close eye on what
the admins are up to as well.
So Rishi's gonna show you
a quick example of that.
RISHI DHAND: Sure, thanks Allan.
So as Allan just
mentioned, it's very
important for
super-admins, especially
in large organizations,
where there
is a hierarchical structure,
a lot of delegated admins,
also super-admins,
to keep tabs on what
the new super admins are doing.
So I'll quickly show you
on how that could work.
So we have a delegated
admin, Shivani, who's
logging into her admin console.
And she's been given a services
admin role, which basically
means she's in charge of
managing settings for each
of the applications.
So I go to my server
settings, I go to my Drive,
and she's been tasked with
reviewing sharing settings
and taking appropriate
actions there.
And as I go there, I have
decided to uncheck this,
and by mistake, I also uncheck
another setting that says,
warn the user when you're
sharing outside of the domain.
So I uncheck it, by
mistake, and I save it.
So this has basically changed
it for the entire company.
And as a super admin who
has all the privileges,
I can go back to
reporting and check
on admin audit, which
basically gives you
a full list of all the
actions that admins are doing.
So there I see that
Shivani, who's the admin,
has gone and changed the sharing
outside the domain setting
and removed the warning while
the sharing is happening.
And at the same time,
I've also got an alert
saying that this setting
has been changed by Shivani.
I'm not happy about it,
because I'm the super admin.
and this has weakened the
security of my company.
Because she has gone ahead
and removed the warning
from users when they're
sharing outside of the domain.
So I can simply go back, look
for her username in the admin
console, and I see one role
has been assigned to her.
And I say manage roles, and
I uncheck the services admin
role, and I say, update.
Because I feel she needs
some more training,
so let's remove her
roles for the time being,
and she can go
back, get trained,
and then we can trust
her with admin assignment
after this is done.
So this is how super-admins
have a very powerful control
through admin audit,
because admin audit keeps
a close watch on
admin activities
that are happening not
just on admin console,
but even using API.
It's a very powerful
mechanism to keep in control.
So with that, I'll just
hand it back to Allan.
ALLAN LIVINGSTON: Great.
Thanks, Rishi.
And so that's given
you a high level
look at some key capabilities
in the admin console
around reporting.
Now there's an awful
lot more there,
but we picked a
few examples that
really highlight some
of the key things
that you want to focus in on.
However we talked
earlier that that
isn't the extent of our
reporting and analysis
strategy.
We also want to ensure that
we've got good integrations Via
an API.
And the one that we're really
excited about is BigQuery.
And we're really excited about
that because of the power
and the flexibility of BigQuery.
Our large customers have custom
and advanced requirements
that we couldn't
hope to possibly meet
in a single console.
They've got specific
compliance needs,
they've got risk,
legal assessments
that they need to do.
They also want to mix data
from multiple sources.
And very importantly,
they want to be
able to spread the insights
out to targeted individuals
in their company, not just
to delegated admins, right?
They want to syndicate
out this information
and they want to really,
really control it.
And that's where
BigQuery comes in.
We've got this connection
between or admin reports
and our admin data, and it's
able to flow into BigQuery.
And what Rishi is
going to do, is
he's going to walk you through
a few different scenarios that
are showing just the amazing
slice and dice that you've
got in BigQuery, and also
the really, really powerful
and, to be honest, very
beautiful visualization
that is present in
Data Studio that's
connected in there as well.
So Rishi, I'll hand
over to you, and you
can run us through that.
RISHI DHAND: Sure.
Thanks, Al.
ALLAN LIVINGSTON: Thank you.
RISHI DHAND: So I
just want to highlight
with BigQuery integration,
what we are offering is,
admins can now directly export
data from their admin console
to BigQuery.
And this is really important
because it cuts down
the entire effort to build an
application, to call our APIs,
and then from API, put
the data into BigQuery.
So this is a direct
route that admins have.
And just to tell you a little
bit about the feature itself.
It's secure, because when
you go to admin console,
and it looks at the signed
in admin's credentials
and only shows those BigQuery
projects where this admin has
editable rights on.
So that he cannot take this data
to any other BigQuery project.
It is pretty scalable, and
its one check enablement,
so the configuration
is pretty lightweight.
And after this push
is done, admins
can use BigQuery to write
scalable custom queries,
or they can create their own
reports using Data Studio.
So I will quickly show you
what this report looks like.
So let's see one such report.
So there you go.
So there's this
report, which admin
can create for collaboration.
So this shows how different
users inside the company
are collaborating across
different applications.
Very beautiful, very custom,
and it's very easy to build.
Similar to this, I
can do another report,
which shows you a comparison
between different OUs.
So this is a classic
CIO staff, where
you want to compare different
teams, how different teams are
using different Google products.
And I can customize this
by choosing specific OUs.
So NA is North America.
I choose North
America, and I want
to compare that with email.
So there you go.
So as a CIO I'm
able to compare how
different teams
inside my company
are able to compare usage across
different Google products.
There is also another
important report
that I can create
around security.
So this report shows me
how files are being shared
broken down by visibility.
So whether it's external,
outside the domain, internal--
Don't and I can break it down.
And I can run some more
filters on top of this.
For example, if I just want
to see public in the domain.
I can click on this, and it
shows me public in the domain.
And then I can apply
further filters
to get more of this thing.
More granularity.
Now if I want to
edit this report,
and say, add a new
page, I can simply
choose one of the
available widgets.
I can break it down.
There you go.
So I was able to create exact
same report right in front
of you I can also
select a filter,
choose the visibility type.
There you go.
So I just created a
report in few seconds,
showing me how files are getting
shared outside my company.
And that's the
power of BigQuery.
Once you have the
data out there,
you can connect
it to Data Studio,
run visualizations,
and customize it
in a matter of seconds.
And that's what makes this
feature very, very exciting
and very powerful.
With this, I'll
hand it back to Al.
ALLAN LIVINGSTON: Great.
Thank you, Rishi.
Now I'd like thank you
guys for coming today.
Say I was an admin
walking into this session.
There'd probably be
two thoughts on my mind
when I was coming in.
First question is, how can
I secure my company's data?
What policies do I need to set
up, and how can I detect that?
That's one piece.
I hope we've addressed that.
The second question
that I might ask
is, what inspired this
lovely carpet choice?
And we can't help there.
I have no idea.
[MUSIC PLAYING]